hey uh kenny and shaq i i think i have  good news for you too  damon fishard producer tells me this is  your last segment which means  if i'm not mistaken this is your last  segment of the entire  nba season wait a minute  [Laughter]  i thought that would make you happy i  thought you might like that news  that's right  the one thing about it you know it is  it's bitter and it's sweet  you're finished but you want to see how  it ended  you know you want to be part of that so  i do kind of miss the fact that i'm not  going to be part of but i won't miss it  long  you're tired from them jumping jacks i'm  tired as hell  i just want to say i love you guys you  know how much i love you isaiah steve  kenny matt  i want to say i appreciate you guys and  uh i'll see you in  october we love you too  you've i love summer to buy some pants  jack  matt and the words of chris tucker don't  worry about what i'm going to be doing  [Laughter]  hi bon voyage fellas  enjoy the rest of this summer